okay a lot of questions are also coming
in about the debates three debates have
been agreed to in principle between Joe
Biden and Donald Trump don't yet know
when they will be where they will be
will there be an audience I don't have
the details yet but the question I'm
getting from a lot of people is
essentially how can we expect Biden to
do in debates against Trump a lot of
right-wingers are saying Trump Biden
dimentia Biden can't put together a
sentence so let's put aside the hot
takes about Biden can't speak he's
completely demanded at this point III
think that what we have to understand is
first of all historically our
expectations about this debate is going
to destroy this candidate or that
candidate that happens very rarely in
high-level politics in the United States
from my perspective Donald Trump so
thoroughly embarrassed himself against
Hillary Clinton in the debates in 2016
the debates did not move the needle
particularly and Trump ended up winning
as we all know when the Democratic
primary just a few months ago feels like
years ago but it was a few months ago
when the Democratic primary this year
got down to Bernie versus Biden you had
the same Biden dementia people saying as
soon as Bernie gets a shot against Biden
one-on-one Bernie's gonna crush him
Biden is not gonna be able to take it
and Biden did fine in that debate now
there are people who said after the fact
well it was because the moderators
helped by by making it all about
coronavirus over listen people some
people were convinced there was no way
Biden would even be able to string
together a sentence that was coherent
Biden did fine and went on to win the
the primary very very handily so if
you're expecting some Black Swan event
where we know every once in a while a
debate does change a race drastically
you're probably going to be disappointed
I do concede and I've been saying this
for a while Joe Biden at 78-77 is not
the Joe Biden that debated paul ryan for
example back in 2012
so I believe Biden knows this I believe
the people around Biden know it so I
would expect Biden to train for a
scenario that favors him so knowing how
to get under Trump's skin without
putting himself in situations for maybe
the type of rapid fire that would not be
playing to his strengths at this point
in time that certainly you know may be a
case this has not you know on the on the
Trump side people preparing him for the
debate are going to be probably in a
futile manner trying to get him to think
about the debates in a way where he
won't end up saying something racist or
xenophobic or discriminatory or or so
you know I want less testing because
then we find fewer cases or whatever so
my vision is that the debates are likely
going to be underwhelming for anybody
expecting really the types of fireworks
that you see once in a blue moon that
shake up a race remember according to
the polls Trump is going to be coming
into these debates playing from behind
but with the power of incumbency if Joe
Biden can simply and this is not an
endorsement of any policy if Joe Biden
can show up and present himself as the
elder statesman diplomat alongside this
unhinged wild wacky Trump doesn't have
to change that many minds that will
probably be good enough for Joe Biden to
maintain his lead
what else did I want oh one other thing
I wanted to mention there are people who
are hoping that the debates will be Joe
Biden calling out Trump's belligerents
and Trump's insane comments and Trump's
comments about women and about black
people and all this different stuff it
just doesn't really work that well right
I mean we've seen that it hasn't worked
well as something to hurt Trump during
the campaign and during his presidency
what has really hurt Trump recently has
been failure on coronavirus subsequent
failure on the economy failure on on his
embarrassing response to the protests
against police brutality
that's where Biden should focus because
we've seen that the stuff that does just
load off or you know slide off of Trump
is the stuff about grab them by the
you-know-what where's my
african-american tweeting the white
power video I don't think that there's
really a winning strategy there for
Biden I think the strategy is look at
the stuff that's gone wrong Trump trying
to gut Obamacare during a pandemic right
that's where the focus should be from a
policy standpoint for Joe Biden